hello everyone we are pleased to have
you join us for cardinal health lab
exchange welcome to today's live
broadcast the view from Washington I am
Judy Oracle black roots and I'll be your
moderator for today's webinar you are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by Cardinal Health Cardinal
Health is a fortune 22 company that
improves the cost effectiveness of
healthcare as the business behind
healthcare cardinal health helps
pharmacies hospitals and ambulatory
surgery centers clinical laboratories
and physician offices focus on patient
care while reducing costs enhancing
efficiency and improving quality
Cardinal Health employs more than 34,000
people worldwide for more information
please visit www comm you have a few
important announcements before we begin
this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you have any technical problems viewing
or hearing this presentation please
click on the support button at the top
right of your presentation window or
submit your problem through the green
Q&A button lower left I would now like
to introduce today's speaker Michael BB
mr. Beebe is a senior vice president at
add me where he advises clients on all
aspects of reimbursement and strategic
policy planning including specific
coding strategies in the physician
office in hospital or other health care
provider settings he directs a DS device
and diagnostic practices mr. Beebe has a
Bachelor of Arts from Penn State
University and a master's degree from
Boston University I will now turn it
over to Michael baby for his
presentation
great thank you very much Jeep
appreciate the introduction I'm going to
talk to you today about what's going on
in Washington DC it's going to be a
little bit talking a little bit about
what has passed the implications of the
legislation that has recently passed the
protecting access to Medicare act of
2014 also known as pama and then also
the Medicare access and chip
reauthorization act or macra that just
asked earlier this year back in April
2015 we'll talk about those that passed
what they potentially mean for physician
practices for reimbursement and then
we'll also talk a little bit about
possible legislation that's going to be
upcoming for most likely in 16 or 17 the
21st century cures bill that's now going
through the house and then repeal of the
medical device tax which something that
we're very involved with which is also
just a further behind the Cure drillbit
girls going through the house then we're
going to turn to the regulatory side
look at what I'm framing a common old
regulation the different the physician
fee schedule hospital inpatient or
outpatient clinical lab what's expected
from them in the coming months and then
a new regulation which is the
implementation of Pama that's actually
overdue and it's been expected for some
time now so that's a a a lot of work
when you're talking about today so first
we're going to turn to the protecting
access to Medicare Act pama pama was
part of the doc fix legislation which is
no more as of the passage of the SGR fix
which is a repeal rather which we're
going to talk about next but the Pamela
legislation use the doc fix as a
legislative vehicle and it of course fix
the SGR temporarily and provided the
shortfall a positive increase for
but also most of the chagrin of many
delayed the implementation of icd-10
until October 2015 that was actually
quite unexpected kind of slid in there
towards the end and it reallocates the
medicare sequester for 20 2024 resulting
in sequestration cuts of 4% the first
six months of this year and zero for the
last six months of the years a little
bit of relief there and it also contains
several significant policy and changes
for the clinical lab fee schedule so
let's talk about those a little bit what
the drivers are from those changes
overall of course the drivers for these
payment changes in CL FS and clinical
that fee schedule are of course
increases that are being seen or are
expected in the clinical lab fee
schedule there's been a really rapid
uptake in molecular diagnostics genetic
testing with the cost of many of these
innovative tests are pretty high there's
also of course substantial investment on
the part of labs to do the research
development on these tests there's a lot
of payer clarity and understanding of
how the tests are perform the
indications for the test the pathology
and genetic signatures that the tests
are looking for and there's also a lack
of standards of evidence so some of the
changes you are not just around painted
but they're also around local coverage
determinations by Medicare contractors
that get at some of the coverage issues
and evidentiary issues and there's also
the clinical and a few schedule itself
is quite antiquated it hasn't been
revised since the you know substantially
since the late 1980s it's very old
methodology and it's a little challenge
for many of these advanced diagnostic
laboratory tests so let's talk a little
bit about what the specific changes are
there's going to be a new payment
methodology the clinical lab fee
schedule there's going to be a new
unique process for
being hit picks codes and other codes
for tests on the clinical lab fee
schedule there's a requirement for CMS
HHS to adopt and expert advisory panel
local mac coverage Authority is changed
to be much more explicit around covering
local requiring local coverage
determinations and not just memos or de
facto changes and then there's also a
requirement for Gao and edgy studies to
look at the impact of some of these
changes so first off Pam establishes two
classes of diagnostic testing the first
class is defined as advanced diagnostic
tests and these are tests that are
furnished by single lab not sold for use
by a lab other than the original lab and
it requires one of the following that
the test is an analysis of multiple
biomarkers DNA RNA or proteins that
combined with the unique algorithm to
yield a single patient specific result
the cpt system caused least n triple A's
or multi analyte algorithmic analyses
it's quite a mouthful arms easier to say
and Triple A another requirement an
additional requirement rather is that
the test is cleared or approved by the
FDA as many of you know FDA clearance is
not required in the space currently
though that might change maybe because
I've not another regulatory update but
it's currently not required so a lot of
these tests are currently lab developed
srl DTS another potential requirement is
that the test meets other similar
criteria established by the secretary
and that's you know a big who knows what
and that's why a lot of observers are
very anxiously awaiting the regular
regulations on pama so the non advanced
diagnostic tests of basically all other
tests listed on the
collapse fee schedule and he knows that
this is only in the clinical app fee
schedule does not get into laboratory
tests such as fluorescence to do
hybridization or immunohistochemistry
which are on the physician fee schedule
so these changes in pama policy and and
payment do not get into the physician
tests the next slide here so where the
pricing changes specifically that pin
was going to implement from the advanced
diagnostic laboratory tests CMS will
issue a temporary code it does not need
to be a cpt code it can be some other
type of HitFix kodak you code or g-code
really know how that's going to work yet
and that's why we're anxiously awaiting
the regs on this the proposed regs but
for the first three quarters the lab
will be able to set their own rates a
lot of people compare this to
pharmaceutical type pricing but there's
not going to be existing constraints
that are on clinical lab fee schedule
test to crossville and a crosswalk or
gap fell so this visa will be able to
set their own price for the first three
quarters and then the fourth quarter CMS
will set the price a median of the
commercial prices that have been
submitted so the lab is expected for
those first three quarters to report
prices that is received from commercial
payers to the Medicare program and then
Medicare will base the actual fourth
quarter price and final price on the
median weighted median of all those
submitted commercial rates pretty big
change there is a grad back for median
prices that are lower than the price
that was initially set by the lab for
the first three quarters so the lab does
need to be accurate and the lab does
need to work to to only sell or only
provide services in the commercial side
where they can meet that initial you
know rate that they want to achieve so
the also for these advanced diagnostic
the feeling will be revised every single
year on the clinical lab feast as those
who no longer will it be static rates
that every single year the fee would be
changed based on all the data that
submitted to Medicare by the lab on
commercial prices that it's been paid to
run to perform the test so that's a
pretty significant change for the
clinical at fee schedule where the rates
were very static previously on the non
advanced diagnostic lab test side
initially the price will be set based on
gas flow or crosswalk which is the
current methodology labs are just like
on the other side they are expected to
report the commercial payments but on
the non advanced diagnostic tests the
tests will only be repriced every three
years again based on the median of
commercial rates so it's a little
different so just to make sure we're all
clear for the existing tests it's it's a
weighted median done every three years
to the clinical data fee schedule and
again this this will apply to hospital
labs for tests paid separately and not
part of the bundle okay it's going to
take effect in 2017 some between 17 and
19 they'll collect the race and the
changes that result from those repricing
cannot be done it cannot be changed by
more than ten percent after 2020 the
raves can change by as much as fifteen
percent so there is some protection if
you will for these older existing not
advanced diagnostic laboratory tests
when the advanced diagnostic side the
again it's the first three quarter
things at their own price and they then
they expect to to send the price set in
the fourth quarter on the median of all
the criminal reported commercial rates
moving on here the one of the major
changes with pamo was a coding reform
that you will wear because of this
to submit commercial rates and the
requirement to have a code for that from
a lot of diagnostic laboratory tests
that we're either using unlisted codes
where we using codes that were multiple
tests into one code there's a need to
uniquely identify individual tests
whether it's an fda-cleared test like k
rafts egfr or BF or if it's a test like
you know uncle type DX which previously
was using an unlisted code there is a
need to uniquely identify all these
codes now so on all these tests so the
pema legislation creates a unique coding
pathway that would allow CMS to to
provide a temporary code under which
they can submit all the collected data
so that's a pretty significant change
that provides a way to get a temporary
code and then the idea is that you will
transition into a cpt code which was
considered the permanent color another
aspect of Panda is that an advisory
panel would be established under the
Secretary of Health and Human Services
this panel was supposed to be
established by Jan by July first of this
year the authorization for the panel was
completed and signed by secretary
Burwell earlier this year I think in
march or april so it's legal framework
is in place but has not yet been
appointed so observers are certainly
looking forward to that as well another
one of the changes is that max would be
prohibited from making de facto coverage
determinations in the clinical
laboratory space they'll be expected to
use the local coverage determination
process which is a more rigorous process
they have to come out with a draft LCD
they have to vet the draft LCD by onek
public meetings and then they can
finalize the the LCD so they can't just
an issue a memo and cover something or
non cover something d fact out another
major change here is that it does leave
open the possibility for
CMS HHS to aside specifically designated
molecular diagnostic Medicare
contractors as many of you know the
palmetto program in certain
jurisdictions operates a program called
multics that is a molecular diagnostic
contractor and covers pays for analyzes
new tests that come on the market for in
the Medicare program but right now it's
only specific to certain Palmetto
jurisdictions which if you look on this
map rj11 along the mid-atlantic here and
then je which is California and Nevada
jf which is adjacent to je also run by
noridian de facto will take many of the
recommendations from mondex but does not
is not required to but the Pema
legislation allows up to for Medicare
contractors specific to molecular
diagnostics and it's expected that's
going to be a pretty major change in the
molecular diagnostics field but we don't
know yet who those contractors can be
it's imagined that more decks will
certainly be one we really don't know
yet and that's also expected as part of
the regulations pamela also sets up a
process by which the government
accountability office and the office of
the inspector general are expected to
issue reports Gao is inspected at their
report by October first of 2018 this
report is expected to analyze many of
the changes that that would have been
implemented by 2017 the all the
different payment changes that are based
on the commercial payment rates they're
expected to analyze them based on impact
beneficiary access volume of laboratory
tests new codes that are issued an order
to accommodate the reporting that sort
of thing um the OIG is expected also to
come out with a report where they would
analyze top 25 laboratory expenditures
look at implementations of the
to the new payment system that was
created under the bell possible problems
with reporting under the under the
payment system so those are two reports
that were authorized the implementation
timeline many many observers think this
implementation timeline has already
shifted but immediately after enactment
CMS much just must establish the process
for temporary hit picks codes and unique
identifiers they really haven't done
that yet there's been much discussion
with the AMA and mckesson and CMS about
use of different types of codes McKesson
has been has developed in conjunction
with Palmetto a temporary coding system
that's used as part of comment a molex
program and it's it's pretty well known
that they've been working with CMS to
try and get something done there with
McKesson / Palmetto system but we don't
really know yet january fifteenth they
kicked in where the max can only issue
LCDs we've seen that happen with the
moldex program where they're not much
more rigorous and how they develop their
coverage policies and they are how to do
I think a little more rigorous standards
July fifteenth CMS is supposed to
establish the advisory panel we'll see
if that happens it's fun to have slipped
a little bit and then January sixteenth
beginning of next year the labs must
begin recording private pay rates and so
this is a year data collection that CMS
will go through to look at all the rates
that are assigned and of course all the
unique codes need to be a place nor if
that's reporting to occur and then in
January 2017 the market based payment
system and the initial payment period
for on the advanced diagnostics worker
and then October of 18 the GAO report so
that's a that's an overview of the the
panel legislation with respect to the
impact on clinical labs to expect them
to be pretty significant in terms of
payment alabs unique coding for labs and
then
so of course the LCD process um let's
look now another mod that passed earlier
this year the Medicare access and chip
reauthorization Act macra this act is
really notable because of the SGR repeal
and this is a little tongue-in-cheek
here but the SGR has been around for 18
years um pretty much since I've been
involved with the Medicare program and
so did sitting a little bit joke here
that you know Washington throws over and
pigs were spotted flying over the
Capitol and they finally repealed the
SVR but of course the STRs many of you
know is the sustainable growth rate
formula established by see same as meta
was actually hit fuh by congressional
mandate 18 years ago and so formula that
kind of automatically the idea was that
deep politicized Medicare payment and
automatically calculate an update every
single year to the Medicare physician
fee schedule well due to a variety of
changes that occurred in Medicare
utilization that past several years have
seen negative updates and then every
year Congress had stepped in to
legislate a positive update or two you
know minimize the amount of negative
update some cases but of note for
political observers every single year
that bill became a mechanism a vehicle
by which there are potential for new
health care legislation as we saw with
the Pema act so that's actually going to
go away now that the SGR has been
repealed it will be interesting to see
what new vehicles there are for health
care legislation now that the Pamela
legislation is gone or now that the STR
has gone rather so let's look at so what
the SGR repeal actually accomplished so
as I mentioned it's in 18 years where
the Medicare sustainable growth rate
formula will now be replaced by a series
of new reimbursement models that more
closely reflect broader health care
trends such as growing consumerism more
accountability pay for performance paid
for quality and more cost sharing them
as some of these models in the near term
the law is going to prevent that twenty
one percent cut to physicians in the
Medicare physician fee schedule and from
now until 2019 physicians will see one
half of one percent increase every year
so that's expected to add some stability
to the system that was previously and
the potential of being quite up and down
if Congress didn't step in this
legislative package as I mentioned is
going to fundamentally change the way
physicians are paid there's going to be
two new payment avenues that physicians
can choose from that will financially
reward or penalize physicians depending
on how well they improve and coordinate
care then beginning in 2026 CMS is going
to be forced to establish these
different payment rates or won't be it
really won't be a option for physicians
anymore they'll have to choose one
either the alternative payment model or
a merit-based incentive payment system
the alternative payment models based
around ACOs where there's a greater risk
sharing in the part of physician
practices and the merit-based incentive
payment system is the underlying payment
system is still fee for service but
there's much more shift to quality of
care and performance measurement so
let's look at some of these changes here
the alternative payment model is
reimbursing through alternative care
models such as accountable care
organizations providers will receive a
lump sum payment of 5% of their Medicare
payments from 219 2019 to 2024 and then
in 2026 Medicare will adopt two payment
rates for providers paid to an
alternative payment model the rates will
increase point seven five percent and
for others the rates will only increase
point two five percent so clearly
there's an incentive here on the part of
CMS HHS to get health care providers
into alternative
models get them to assume greater risk
by incentivizing them with a five
percent increase and then also the point
seven five percent increase over the the
one quarter of a point increase on the
other side the merit-based incentive
payment system side is going to be based
on how welcome physicians perform on
certain quality measures it's called the
MIPS program the Medicare instead of
based payment system be paid based on
performance against quality measures
that put between four and nine percent
of payments at risk so let's look at the
phasing some of these options under the
merit-based system on the top part here
the they're gonna so you'll have the
point five percent annual update until
2019 and then from 2020 to 2025 that
payment rate is frozen and that's where
the CMS HHS really want to see folk
physicians in to participate or
participation in the merit-based
incentive payment system they'll have
they'll have beginning in 2018 here the
last year on some of those separate
systems that we currently have today
such as the meaningful use system and
the value-based modifier system as well
as the physician quality reporting
system those are all now separate
programs this merit-based incentive
payment system will merge all three of
them together then beginning in 2020
it's going to increase the amount of
that's at risk in those programs in the
new program where they're going to put a
deficit of up to minus five percent or
have a bonus of up to fifteen percent
for physicians in this participating in
this system and then beginning 2022 the
deficit will increase for up to nine
percent to twenty-seven percent on the
high end and this bar here is that there
are two different programs that they
intend to leverage and they clearly want
to try and move people into the higher
risk share program
but there's also going to be initially a
lower risk share model as well we're not
quite as much is put at risk to
physicians who are participating the
lower risk share and they're also not
get quite as much of an increase as well
in the advanced alternative payment
model again they'll participate in the
five percent annual update through 2019
they'll get in 2019 they'll get that
five percent participation bonus and
then what happens here is that beginning
in 2019 to 2020 they want a Medicare
program won't see a gradual shift or
tone up to twenty-five percent goes at
risk and then 20 out of 20 21 and I they
want to see ramped up Medicare all pair
of new requirements were much more
percent is put at risk in the Medicare
program so the the metaphase payment
system as I mentioned before is within
the fee-for-service program but it's
just going to put much more risk you'll
get much more under just regular
fee-for-service it's going to combine
all the existing programs meaningful
years the PQRS and the value-based
modifier is going to adjust Medicare
payments based on performance on a
single budget neutrality payment
beginning 2019 it's going to apply the
physicians all non care non-physician
healthcare professionals so our end
anesthetists physician assistants
audiologist physical therapists etc is
going to include improvement centers for
quality in resource use categories and
you can see the breakdown here in this
pie chart i have over on the right hand
side of the screen where is italy
there's going to be a distribution if
you will across different areas it's all
going to be in one program but there's
going to be certain allocations of
emphasis so it's fee on the risk based
models of the advanced payment models
here there's going to be a significant
share provider revenue in the advanced
payment model with a two-sided risk and
quality measurement or in some cases
participation certified patient-centered
medical homes there's going to provide
financial incentives five percent annual
bonus and exemption from the other
quality measures that are on the other
side of the fee-for-service then this
program is going to have its own quality
measures it's going to include partial
qualifying mechanism that allow
providers that fall short of the
requirements to report quality measures
received corresponding incentives or to
decline to participate in this quality
measure so it's going to be the
intention is to make this a little bit
flexible and you can see on this table
on the right where there is an increase
in cost share here and i got my boxes
and little discolored that's over on the
right option to on the those two boxes
the box on the left the lower box lower
percentage is this video player model so
they do want to share some the risk with
other non-medicare players here as well
so with the implications here in the
near term this package is going to
provide greater of physician payment
certainty the reliance each year on a
duck's fix forced many physicians
practices to really think about what
they are going to spend their capital
money on and the thinking among members
of Congress and certainly encouraged by
the am a physician groups was that the
instability of physician payment cause
many physicians not to invest in high
capital products such as electronic
medical records and whatnot so the idea
here is that with greater stability but
we better opportunity for investment so
these are some of the quality reporting
programs are going to go away the new
Ron corporate's all of the
sisting three quality reporting programs
into one big quality reporting program
it eliminates the individual bonuses and
penalties under the individual ones
intend to combine them all into one big
program because this going to put much
much more illness back onto the
physician they need to assess the
patient population they need to assess
their level of risk and have really good
at a really good understanding of the
patients that they careful in order to
participate in this so it's going to
require a cue understanding the patient
demographics physicians practices should
determine which reimbursement bottle is
best for them based on their ability to
deliver care to a wide swath of the
their practice community so let's move
on from legislation that's been passed
to legislation that's potentially
pending I say potentially says really
hard to say was going to go out of this
21st century cures is making its way
through the house right now recently
passed out on Energy and Commerce in in
april of this year and where the idea
here with the 21st century cures
legislation is that to provide greater
industry-wide incentives to innovate to
reduce some of the some of the barriers
to innovation and provide incentives to
innovate so the bill is HR 6 it was
based on discussion draft that was
introduced in May of 2015 expected to
cost 13 billion and it was as I said
passed out of energy and commerce in May
of 2015 so let's look at some of the
comments here it was originally
introduced and they have 14 various
white papers were published forms were
held to discuss it the first draft
discussion was January 15 second draft
discussion April
a tooth a PO end of April 2015 and then
it it's on a pretty rapid track here so
far but it passed on Energy and Commerce
in May of 2015 Senate Finance however
has said that I'm really not that
they're not interested in taking out
this legislation this year so it's going
to be put off until 16 at least 16 but
what are the objectives of it it's a
it's a comprehensive look at the steps
required to accelerate the pace of
innovation in in the United States it's
looking at the full arc of healthcare
innovation from the discovery in basic
science to streamlining drug and device
development process digital medicine
social media and the treatment delivery
phase legislation designed to speed
discovery development into livery of new
medical treatments to patients by
streamlining clinical research creating
more flexible medical device and drug
approval pathways for industry is passed
through Energy and Commerce and included
13 billion in offsets which is a pretty
impressive mostly based on the
production of regulation and provided
550 million new mandatory funding for
the FDA in order to achieve that and
Fredman has acknowledged that the 21st
century cures provides both sides of the
aisle with a great deal to benefit and
so he sees this as being able to go
through so live with some of the
sections to watch in this drug discovery
section which is sections 1101 11110 to
which look at NIH funded research data
clinical trial registry data bank for
for clinical trials development sections
2021-22 2181 qualification of drug
development tools accelerated approval
development plan enhance the combination
products to review how CMS reviews
combination products like drug-eluting
stents prior review from breakthrough
devices and then easing regulatory
burden with respect to certain classes
of devices then delivery ensuring
interoperability healthcare information
technology telehealth services and
treatment certain items or devices so
this as i mentioned increases nih
funding it this section when the one
directs the director of nih to not
require sharing of data it's
inconsistent with applicable laws and
policy to increase privacy
confidentiality proprietary interest
business confidence iya confidentiality
information intellectual property rights
and other relevant rights section 1102
standardizes the data in a clinical
trial data bag this is again the idea
here is to streamline data collection to
make it more efficient in the
development section drug development
tools to direct the first section direct
secretary to establish the process for
the qualification of drug development
tools for a proposed context useless
specified by the requester for the
purpose the term drug means any
biomarker clinical outcome assessment or
any other method material on major like
your secretary use to age and drug
development there's an accelerated
approval plan in this section that
allows FDA to accelerate the approval
development of certain drugs and
biomarkers there's an enhanced
combination product review as I
mentioned before which are products
potentially products that are biomarkers
where you go through with a combination
of biomarker and therapy then there's
easing regulatory burden with certain
class 1 class 3 devices
this this delivery section is the
interoperability of health information
technology where allows clarifies that
technology must satisfy criteria in
order for health IT to be considered
interoperable to secure transfer
complete access to healthcare data no
information blocking and create
categories for interoperability
standards in the health services on
Medicare program it allows the Cure's
allows for a report on populations of
Medicare beneficiaries or dual eligibles
those with chronic conditions those who
may be improved through telehealth
services right now Medicare telehealth
program is extremely narrow and and this
will allow for a greater expansion
treatment of certain devices and items
its focus on disposable medical
technologies by mending Act to include
payment for certain disposable medical
devices and this is a new sub category
that's enabled by enhanced electronics
miniaturization it's no longer you know
just a disposable device or terminal
medical equipment there's there's more
greater interplay and this creates a new
category of disposable devices that used
to be maybe just DME a member piece of
legislation that's certainly being
encouraged by the medical device
industries that repair the medical
device tax the tax went into effect as a
result of the Affordable Care Act there
was one of the main offsets in the
Affordable Care Act I went into effect
December 31st 2012 and imposes an excise
tax in the sale of certain medical
devices by the manufacturer or the
porter of the devices the ways Means
Committee sponsored a by Eric Paulsen
was introduced protect medical
innovation Act 2015 in early January it
would repeal that
House Ways and Means Committee actually
earlier this week approved the bill to
repeal the tax with some Democratic
support the full chamber is expected to
pass the measure later this month and
lawmakers have nuts yet said how they
would offset online loss the medical
device tax on the let's look a little
bit at some of the regulatory rules now
that are both expected and then some
that had been pending out for quite a
while so in the Medicare program you
every single year you expect to have a
physician rule expect to have a hospital
inpatient rule a hospital outpatient and
ASC rule and then also the clinical lab
fee schedule rulemaking process on the
physician side the proposed world every
year is expected at early July usually
just in time for the July fourth weekend
this year the proposed rule for the
first time will include new and revised
CPT codes that are due to go into effect
January first of next year usually those
new new codes only appear in the final
rule this time CMS is asked the the AMA
in specialty societies to accelerate
their code development and valuation
process so for the first time many are
going to appear in the proposed rule and
then the final rule will be published in
November for implementation in January
first on the hospital outpatient side
the proposed rule comes out at the same
time as the physician fee schedule and
that's expected again July 4th weekend
and to take effect the final rule in
November some of the big changes that
are expected there is that CMS is
expected to in some way continue its
packaging initiative that it began two
years ago where they created the
comprehensive a pcs eliminated add-on
codes eliminated the ability to
build some mud with different adjacent
services and became much more of a
prospective payment system on the
inpatient side a proposed rule was
published in April we expect the final
rule to be published in October and the
inpatient side they also have a new
packaging initiative based on some new
episodes of care the clinical lab fee
schedule CMS announced last week then
intends to hold a public meeting July 16
2015 will they will look to gap fill or
crosswalk for all new codes but the big
one really waiting for is is the pinna
implementation and as I mentioned
earlier under the presentation payment
limitations been expected as originally
expected first quarter of this year it's
been delayed but this implementation
regulation is expected to provide
guidance on reporting for commercial
payments which is key definition of the
advanced diagnostic laboratory tests
whether or not they're going to include
fda cleared drug diagnostic tests in
that definition and what you know
possibly companion diagnostic tests so
the development of temporary codes and
the temporary codes can be maintained by
the AMA the temporary codes going to be
maintained by McKesson or Palmetto as
eyes as they have requested to do and
then the advisory panel the coverage of
payment because it's going to be makeup
of that panel who's going to participate
how much influence they going to have
etc so all that is expected out of the
pen implementation and that finally is
it that concludes the overview of recent
and expected legislation and regulation
so I'll be dope new questions
thank you for that informative
presentation I am thrilled to be a part
of Cardinal Health land exchange before
we get started on the question and
answer session I'd like to remind our
audience how to submit questions you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can following this presentation head
over to the community of learning in the
lab exchange lobby to have the
opportunity to engage in live chat and
have more of your questions answered on
spot about the view from Washington give
people a moment to ask questions and you
know it appears there are no questions
from the audience at this time so i just
want to remind everyone to head over to
the lab exchange lobby so you can engage
in live chat and have your questions
answered directly by michael BTW i would
like to thank our sponsor cardinal
health for making today's educational
webcasts possible again make sure to
head over to the community of learning
to right now to speak with michael baby
and i'll answer your request sir
questions directly today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through October of this year you'll
receive an email from lab roots alerting
you when this webcast will be available
for replay and we invite you to afford
that announcement to your colleagues you
may have missed today's live event see
you next time goodbye